scp 682 versus scp-1437  could dropping 682 in a hole to another  place finally get rid of it for good to  begin the test 682 was thrown into 1437  at 1 hour 3 minutes 23 seconds  scp-682 was expelled from 1437 in the  shape of a large glass object filled  with a red blood-like liquid an on-site  bulldozer pushed it back down the hole  at 13 hours 12 minutes 7 seconds scp-682  was expelled from the hole again in the  form of a round mechanical device that  released a dangerous gas and had a mouth  full of gold teeth the bulldozer pushed  it back down at 27 hours 20 minutes  scp-682 was propelled out of 1437 it had  returned to its original shape with the  exception of a larger body shorter snout  and a variety of weapons embedded in its  body